on vous en parlait dans l'édition de
lundi l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien de trappes endeuillée par la
disparition du docteur jacques fribourg
un décès des suites du colis de 19 ans
ce médecin urgentiste de 68 ans avait
pris sa retraite en septembre 2019
il était revenu au centre hospitalier en
pleine crise du coronavirus pour
s'engager dans la lutte auprès de ses
confrères et nous sommes avec un de ses
confrères le docteur romain mario zoulou
wallonie bonjour bonjour
donc vous êtes médecin urgentiste à
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien déjà
comment vous allez dans ce contexte de
crise sanitaire
c'est compliqué c'est plein de plein de
sentiments on tient le coup mais c'est
quand même compliqué puis ça l'est
encore plus depuis la semaine dernière
le shaq jacques ccc c'est un symbole
pour nous aider son hôpital dans son
établissement depuis un mois et s'est
battu comme un diable pour survivre et
il décède chez nous c'est un sentiment
c'est beaucoup de tristesse c'est
énormément de tristesse
cc c'est particulier de voir partir
quelqu'un pour lequel on avait quand
même beaucoup de respect beaucoup
d'admiration beaucoup d'amitié d'amour
de voir partir dans ces conditions huit
mois après son après sa retraite
j'ai pas vraiment de mots pour ça c'est
compliqué après nous si vous voulez
savoir mois et demi qu'on se bat pour le
contre connard en corner
ce métier donc je suis pas juge et moi
j'ai l'impression un peu d'être d'être
dedans de la tête j'étais dans d'idron
est bon on verra plus tard tu crois que
je réfléchis pas trop en termes de
personnellement à titre personnel je
vois là je suis plutôt inquiet sur la
situation actuelle
le confinement déconfinement percussions
mon cas personnel
je pense pas trop en fait j'ai vite
somme la tristesse par rapport à la
disparition du docteur jacques rigaud
c'est quelqu'un que vous côtoyez depuis
longtemps ça fait 12 ans je suis arrivé
en 2008
jacky était déjà très impliqué puisqu'il
fait partie des trois fondateurs du
service avec les docteurs joël renou
vecteur françois thivet les deux
premiers enfin françois et il jouait son
parti restait donc à jacques tits de
très investi et puis j'ai des
coordinateurs du service un pendant sept
ans donc j'étais un peu comme personnes
qui reprennent donc on est et on était
très lié justement sur les sur deux
projets de projets de services
il a beaucoup appuyé aussi pour la
rénovation de notre service initialement
voix après le projet il n'a pas eu la
passion vie puisqu'il était
effectivement un peu en retrait mais il
a quand même beaucoup fait justement
pour qu'un seul ce projet puisse en tout
cas être initié par le le groupe
générale de santé
et voilà et puis jacques ont travaillé
ensemble tous les jours il ya chaque
fois qu'on est très régulièrement sein
du service donc oui c'est une car j'ai
côtoyé pendant 12 ans qui faisait partie
de notre fan notre famille il faisait
partie de la famille des semences vous
l'avez dit le docteur jacques fribourg
avait pris sa retraite en septembre 2010
n'est fait il revient dans cette crise
quel regard vous portez sur ce geste sur
ce geste de mobilisation c'est un geste
admirable et moi qui me paraît en même
temps comme jeudi et à meaux naturel par
deux guerres virologique ainsi on parle
de nuit la place d'un soldat canton en
temps de guerre donc jacques comme
beaucoup d'autres ont pris le parti de
se réinvestir comme lieu pouvait jacques
était très très attaché à sa mission au
samu nous en parlait énormément la vidéo
de la régulation téléphonique
principalement produit c'était une
évidence de continuer cette mission par
le biais justement du samu et moi je
suis je suis très admiratif de ce qu'il
a fait et en étant très attristé parce
que parce que parce que du coup il s'est
investi dans une mission qu'il a peut
être remporté je sais pas peut-être
bah je sais pas en tout cas c'est dur
c'est dur de devoir finir comme ça en
tout cas
quels souvenirs vous garderez de lui
être une anecdote quelque chose des
moments que vous avez vécu et jacques
c'était un très très bon vivant donc il
aimait beaucoup la musique mais beaucoup
les copains les métiers où beaucoup la
bonne bouffe le bon petit coup à boire
de temps en temps mais votre travail
vous imaginez bien mais voilà c'était
quand il était de garde la première
question qui posait quand il arrivait
c'était de savoir ce qu'on avait
commandé à manger il est bien qu'on lui
tapote sur le ventre il aimait bien
parler de tweets ou n'importe quoi et il
avait une voix particulière d'eau qui
faisait qu'on disait parce que bon il
parait un peu dans sa barbe et tout ça
ça faisait rire tout le monde mais ça
faisait partie du personnage et il était
très attachant il avait comme si son
caractère donc c'était quelqu'un avec
qui on pouvait s'cusez moi du terme
s'engueuler mais il n'y avait pas de
ressentiment en tout cas il n'y avait
pas de risque de le voir être rancunier
donc
donc voilà donc c'était la vie un
jacques c'était un c'était c'était un
homme de vie en fait voilà donc tout ce
qu'on peut connaître dans une vie on
vivait avec lui au quotidien
et voilà c'était gcc difficile 1 2 par
des danses et plein de sentiments que
j'ai l'impression pas pouvoir tout
décrire un meilleur suivi très attristé
par la parole un dernier mot comment
vous voyez si on parle début de la crise
sanitaire comment vous voyez là les
prochains jours l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire
pour finir sur feu sur la description de
cette espèce très rapidement beaucoup
d'inquiétude beaucoup d'inquiétude parce
que parce que justement donc les gens
vont ressortir que pour l'instant le
niveau de circulation du virus en corner
de france et quand même je pense encore
relativement élevé bien évidemment il
est compliqué de tenir encore une
population sous confinement et on se
rend bien compte un arrêté que les
censeurs temps mais moi je suis très
inquiet et je pense que mon corps risque
effectivement de voir développer une
deuxième vague a c'est la grande
inquiétude de tous les professionnels
tentent de santé de voir cette eau
deuxième vague et là nous on a
énormément de difficultés si vous voulez
respect des patients n'ont que vides
ressort donc nous il faut qu'on en
interne on s'organise avec encore de
flux mais influent pour l'instant que
wiedeking qui est très faible mais qui
mobilise encore beaucoup de personnel et
l'autre côté un flux non que vides qui
commence aussi à embouteiller pas mal de
services
et puis on sait pas comment réagir on
sait pas comment s'adapter c'est très
difficile de s'adapter
c'est une adaptation au quotidien donc
pour l'instant en fait nous c'est
surtout de l'inquiétude par rapport à
une deuxième vague savoir comment on va
être amené à la gérer donc on verra à
partir d'eux ni jouant ce que ça que ça
ce que ça va occasionner merci docteur
romain maillot de l'ol ni pour ce votre
témoignage
et pour faire vous merci à vous de nous
avons dit c'est le temps pouvoir
justement nous exprimer dans leur antre
va chaque merci beaucoup merci à vous et
bon courage pour la poursuite de vinci
de vos activités dans cette crise
sanitaire
merci au revoir